[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan just got shocked
by the microphone no it was in my head
oh it was all in your head and you
didn't really get no no no
i know the headphones shocked my ears
from inside i'm sorry i'm not safe man
i'm sorry i don't know why that happened
i'm the worst superhero geez louise hey
thanks for listening to the podcast
thanks for uh taking the time and being
interested in me and the podcast i
appreciate that um
if you like the podcast or if you're
here for kristin krug don't go away
make sure you follow us on the handles
ryan at inside to be pod on twitter
inside to be podcast on instagram and
facebook that's correct follow us write
a review please if you like the
interview write a review really helps
the show and subscribe watch on youtube
subscribing really helps and i think
you'll like the show not just because
you're a christian krug fan but she's
amazing um and a lot of other stuff
going on make sure you go to the inside
of you online store we've got new lunch
boxes signed by me and tom welling
smallville lunch boxes a bunch of mugs
tumblers shirts pictures autographs
inside of you online store you can also
go to sunspin.com to get any stuff that
you want from the band sunspin hats uh
this and that we're playing
february 26th two shows saturday
february 26 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
come join us the band there's prizes
you'll zoom with us it's fun trust me
new people came last week they had a
blast
um that's about all i have to say about
that also if you want to help the
podcast in other ways there's a thing
called patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com slash inside of
you
join my patron be a patron i'll message
you right after you join uh patrons just
give back to the podcast and really help
the podcast more than you know so join
patreon patreon.com inside of you a big
thanks to ryan my engineer big thanks to
bryce uh my producer jason my editor uh
everybody at cumulus westwood one uh for
keeping the podcast afloat and we're
doing our job we're doing the best we
can
thank you for listening and right now
let's do it lot to talk about let's get
inside of kristin krug it's my point of
view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
you look very festive you have a sort of
uh what are you wearing i like it it's
kind of like uh
the hills it's like a full thing
i like it what it what is it how would
you describe that that's it makes me
think of it not the hills have eyes
that's a horror movie but the other one
the um the hills are alive with the
sound of music
the sound of music you mean i mean i
don't i don't know it's just like a it's
like a overalls but not i like it
me too
where are you
where's home
in toronto i'm in toronto at home in my
in my office now word on the street is
that you might be moving to vancouver
oh yeah you heard about that
yeah what's what's that about
why would you want to be closer to your
family
because i do i want to be closer to my
and you know my sister's got two kids
now and my best friends are there and
you know
i i kind of miss it
um
and it's gonna be weird i've been every
day out here in toronto i'm like oh well
that's not gonna be in vancouver this is
kind of constantly
toronto's just much more cool than
vancouver is why is it cooler is it it's
first of all it's cold it's cold in
toronto
it's not right now i mean vancouver's
been the weather i mean vancouver's been
horrible but you know with climate
change and everything um but
i don't know it's gonna here it's
sunnier more often in toronto it gets
really cold but it's pretty i'm not
gonna miss the cold i hate the cold now
the only thing that kept you there was
burden of truth
no i moved out here
because i wanted to
start producing and
um
and toronto's better in canada for
for that so
i
you know i did that i built a bunch of
connections and i know a bunch of people
here now but
i don't know if it really makes that
much of a difference where i am in the
end and at least i'll be close to
home you know with my parents and my
sister and her kids and my friends and
the mountains and the ocean and all
those things that i love you know i was
talking to welling and the one word that
came up first of all he says hi he sends
his love
hi hi
i just saw him yesterday he listens he
you what
i feel like i just saw him yesterday you
saw him in paris yeah how was paris by
the way you love paris
i
love paris
um it was weird it was crazy it was the
first thing i'd done
you know in the midst of covid uh and it
was packed and and just the convention
was packed a lot of fans
yeah a lot of people were there i mean i
would think it was a smaller space
because i don't think they had
originally expected that many people and
they couldn't get a bigger space so it
was
it was so busy
um
but you know it ended up being fine and
it was nice and it was nice to talk to
everybody and
and the city itself was wonderful i was
there for like a week afterward and it
was sunny the entire time and gorgeous
and the food was delicious and it was
you know everything else you do your
face lights up when when i say paris
it's
it's also just so it's a quite a
that city changes so much there are so
many people that come in the the you
know the food is constantly shifting
there there's um you know in uh
i can't remember i called these malls
right now but in one area there's like a
massive vietnamese population so the
food is like this like there's lots of
great vietnamese food so i love how the
city is
constantly changing and every time you
go it's kind of a new paris and i really
like that that's great you know when you
first started doing smallville you were
kind of like the shy you were young you
were 17 you were do you still
feel i mean obviously you're more mature
you're a woman now you're doing yeah
obviously but when you go to do these
cons do you get anxious do you get
anxiety do you feel like can i do this
can i you know are you are you better
around people because i know you love
people but you're also kind of shy and
you know a little introverted and you're
a reader
[Music]
you're a reader we'll get into that but
um yeah so how do you how do you deal
with it um how do you approach it what's
your mentality when you go into
something like that a big convention
well with like the stuff that we do the
actual
scheduled activities
uh the you know signings or the panel or
whatever i really don't find those
things too stressful what i find more
stressful is like our free time sitting
around with all these
um
you know
types yeah
i don't know
i don't know you guys and i feel really
uncomfortable and i don't know what to
talk to them about so that's always the
most awkward part so you're saying
you're most comfortable around people
and it's the actors and the that side of
it that you're more uncomfortable with
a little bit i mean i think for me it's
all about
like i know what i need to do
on a panel you know i get asked
there obviously is like i'm not a
performer like you are so i don't feel
like
and i don't even feel pressured to
entertain everybody i just feel like i
just have to answer the questions you
really don't you really don't feel like
pressure to be on you've never felt like
that like i have this
propensity to you know just be on to be
the center of attention to because
because that's all i know and if i don't
do that people will think something's
wrong with me in fact you'll look at me
and go what's wrong with you why are you
quiet no it's true i would assume
something was off
if but i do but do you feel like it's
only a pressure do you like doing that
also i think it's exhausting but i feel
compelled to you know kind of get out of
my skin and just you know be more alive
and be more alive with the people that
give them a show give them something
they'll remember and that's exhausting
for me you know it's always being on
it's always then you get home and you're
like oh my god i just want to die and
everybody's like let's go out for dinner
after i'm like no thanks i feel like
[ __ ]
well i think i think the fans really
appreciate that and i actually i think
tom really appreciates that too it's
like you take a
load off for him i i think
he doesn't he's great at that stuff but
i don't think he wants to carry the
entertainment factor um
so
it's
i mean i think you'll appreciate that
you do it yeah and it would be weird if
you didn't do i can't imagine you just
being like
relaxed in a chair just answering
questions
it just doesn't feel like you
maybe the older i get that's what will
happen i'll start to kind of just relax
a little bit and not go with that if you
make that decision i will support you
100 i mean i can't be 70 years old and
beyond can i
you can indeed
and how would you feel about that
see more i'm
wondering what you think i'm worried
about what you'll think as a 70 year old
guy doing if it makes you happy
and it it brings you more joy than
stress
then i would support you being on
at 70. if it brings you more stress and
makes your life worse
then i would suggest you just sit calmly
yeah
but you're enjoying you enjoy yourself
when you go there you know what you're
doing now you you know how to talk to
people you're you're a good spirit but
you don't always feel like you have to
be on you're just in a sense you're just
you aren't you
i try to be i mean it's a heightened me
obviously i am not i i i will
i'm i'm a little more mellow generally
um but yeah i'll i i'm mostly just
myself
right but you know before i got into
this i was like welling says hi and we
were both talking and then we got off on
a tangent on
no it was my fault but uh you know we
were like you know she's a mystery she's
a very
mysterious
person like we were thinking who is
kristen krug
you know what inspires christian crew
you know and i was thinking
uh you know
why aren't we married not you and me
not like i'm not married not you know i
there's there's reasons why but like you
know you're not married you're you're
you're when i first met you you're 17
and now you're you're getting older i'm
a lot i'm still older than you i still
got you beat but you're you're
approaching 40.
yeah i guess
it's interesting like i
i am i believe in like long-term
monogamy monogamous relationships
they're things that i get a lot of
joy and meaning out of it's just
marriage itself feels very like
constructed by society and a society
that i don't
necessarily agree with in every way like
i feel like it's something it's
something that's sold to us as a way to
find some sort of completion or
happiness and i and i don't really
believe that i believe it's a myth and
and i think that
i mean i i mean how
what i've chosen isn't that different
for marriage
so
right like it's not like i am planning
to
just
be polyamorous my whole life right right
like i i prefer
long-term monogamy but
i don't know i just it doesn't feel like
anything i've ever
aspired toward and
in some ways i think that i appear as a
very like conservative person and in
many ways i am but i think my little
rebellions against
what
what i'm sold by my society is what will
make me happy i
they're just my little rebellions now
have you had these conversations with
your boyfriend obviously he's like when
he knows how you feel about this
he has probably you know there he's like
i'm well i'm [ __ ] never asking her to
marry me because i know what the answer
is going to be there i mean is there
sort of that feeling or is it uh do you
think but michael like it's it's
we're all
legally we're married
is that true
yeah essentially common law is the same
thing is there common law in in canada
yeah and in the united states as well i
believe i don't know your laws
specifically but you live together for a
certain amount of time and
it's essentially the same
you know you haven't signed one kind of
a contract but you still need to take
into account that you know if he and i
are to split up
he could sue me for a lot of money you
know
like it's just it's the same it's the
same thing um
yeah and
there's still meaningful conversations
about commitment and about
our intentions and
like all of that feels it's just the
idea of
i don't know in some ways it's as simple
as like going having a wedding or
none of those things mean anything to me
they feel so
devoid of meaning and i suppose that's
because they've
constantly been presented to me as like
some sort of a thing that is like of
importance and i just don't so a big
celebration to celebrate christian crew
getting married and the idea of that is
just yeah you look at me you just looked
at me like no you don't want to again
you don't want that attention you don't
want you don't feel like it's necessary
and it's not something because most
most women i think you know at a young
age oh i want to have kids and grow up
and be married and the guys think the
same way i always thought you know i'd
be married and i'd have kids by now and
but you know you have this more mature
aspect of like the whole or perspective
of
of what marriage is and it's just like i
don't know if it's more mature but i
didn't get so like so my parents never
said to me get married and have kids
that's that's the way your life should
go
my parents were like don't get married
don't get married
unless you're gonna have kids don't get
married and it was never you have to
have kids right
like none of that was ever presented as
my ultimate end place like some sort of
completion of my life so
they never promoted that to me and
honestly my family
like everyone's really different some
people have kids some people don't some
people are married some people are not
like it's just
some people got married older some
people got married younger
i don't have
a family that has all been the same that
way so i've been able to look to
aunts who chose not to get married and
you know
others who chose to get married but
didn't have kids for whatever reason you
know i just everyone chose different
things and i feel really free being able
to like make decisions it's a weird
place to
to
have people think that there's some
[Music]
some proper end
place and if you're not going towards
that you like
aren't
it isn't correct and i don't understand
that i don't understand it either no
it's true i just i think you know
you're right i mean what is it you know
i always think i don't want to be alone
i don't want to be the 70 year old
rambunctious guy that goes to
conventions and is the life of the party
and then goes home and he's alone i like
to find somebody who but that doesn't
mean that i have to get married to them
that just means that i'm with someone so
the whole idea of marriage and i think
your parents are right i think i have a
lot of friends who say
you know i don't want to you know don't
get married if you're not going to have
kids
so you have you always thought about
were you always at a
always the mentality of i don't really
want kids kids are not for me i'm not
that that's not you know because i think
you know i'm a little too selfish
you know and the kids have to be the
center of attention if i have a family
you know that that all has to stop it
has to be like these because my mom
you know my family the dysfunction she
was the center of attention and when you
have kids you can't do that
the kids have to be the center of
attention and so you have to give so
much more so
you know i look at you know maybe the
reason i don't want to get married is
because i look at you know myself as a
child and i'm like i'll be so hard on
myself to be the best father i can be
that i don't want to put the burden
on myself does that make sense
yeah it does
but again i don't know
like you don't want it you don't want to
be alone and that's fair
but i don't know
[Music]
i
i think there are so many ways not to be
alone
yeah
and it depends what you're looking for
so if it's a partner you can have a
partner
you can be married to that partner and
not be married to that partner right
whatever your
choices are like i don't know why it has
to be one way so your parents don't say
anything to you they never say why
aren't you married that's not no
absolutely that's that's usually parents
are like that with with their kids i
know i'm very lucky that way my parents
are are not like that with me they don't
they
they just want me to
you know be happy and doing something
meaningful you know um
yeah so whatever that looks like are
they do you think you know are they
proud of you do you feel like you know i
know at a young age because they were
never parents that came on set right
they were never there they my parents
never really did that either but do you
feel like now after all you've done and
you're you know um
you're very charitable and you're you
know
you just you've done a lot in your life
do you think your parents have you has
your dad ever sat with you and said you
know kristin i'm really proud of you
i mean we've talked about this a little
bit before but yeah i know knowing those
words
you know
and i
do you need to hear it
what do i need to yeah
i think i did at some point and i don't
really know but i don't know if it's so
deeply ingrained in me like like there
is some yeah like some sort of thing i'm
striving to i mean do we ever fully get
rid of that i mean that takes a lot of
work to not want to please your parents
i know i don't know it's kind of what
we're trying to do
but i think i know
what what makes them proud and in some
ways those are the same things that
would make me proud about myself
right
what that comes from i don't know if i
just
internalized all the rules that they
the values
right but i think like
i don't know i look at my life at this
point and i'm like okay i've got it
theoretically hopefully a chunk of time
left and i can start investing more in
my community and that's what i that's
what i want to be able to do like what
we do is really
great and we can talk to a lot of people
we can reach a lot of people but i i
want to be more invested in like the
smallness of my community
um be able to you know volunteer and
make an impact on on the ground and i
think that's kind of what my next
where do you want to volunteer what do
you want to do
well i am interested in so many things
and so that's what i need to figure out
i mean there's um a few women's shelters
in vancouver that i'd like to work with
once i'm there but also you know there
are things that i like on the ground
things i'd love to be able to do just
with you know the environment um
like i
have to start to
suss out
in vancouver specifically because i'm
going back now everyone knows um
everyone knows
well vancouver is a very big place bc is
a big place so it's not like they're
going to know where you are but you know
yeah
exactly exactly no i'm not worried i'm
not worried about that but yeah yeah so
i just need to just get a kind of
foothold in my community and feel
what's going on i feel like i know more
about toronto now than i do vancouver so
inside of you is brought to you by my
good friends at better help better help
online therapy is uh
somebody a company that's been with me
for a while now and um
if you listen to the podcast you
understand why they're really helping
people they're helping people like my
friend ryan here ryan you still go to
better help i still go to better help
and how much is it helping you it is
helping immensely yeah a lot of my
friends are like is this this the real
deal is better help i'm like yeah man
that's a lot of people are using it and
really liking it i get letters
all the time sent to me that say hey
thanks for you know your better help uh
sponsor because they're really helping
me yeah and you know you definitely save
a lot more than going to you know just
getting in your car and going somewhere
um
you know those
therapy sessions are expensive as hell
yeah and better help is definitely a lot
cheaper
you know many people think that
therapies for uh
other people
but utilizing therapy doesn't mean
something's wrong with you it means you
recognize that all humans have emotions
and we need to learn to understand them
not avoid them
and we've been taught
that taking care of our mental health
shouldn't be a part of everyday life but
that's a huge misconception
we take care of our bodies by exercising
going to the doctor eating well
focusing on and investing in the health
of our minds is just as important
better help is customized online therapy
that offers video phone and even live
chat sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to ryan do you see them
on camera i do you like that i like it i
think it helps for me it helps for you
like to see the person it's more of a
some contact some interaction it just
feels
you just see some kind empathetic faces
across from you yeah i like that no uh
like i said it's much more affordable
than in-person therapy and you could be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours look give it a try so many people
have tried this two million people have
been using better help online therapy
and inside of you listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
slash inside that's right ten percent
off for inside of your listeners off
their first month at betterhelp.com
inside that's betterhelp help dot com
slash
inside inside of you is brought to you
by geico geico asks how would you love a
chance to save some money on insurance
well of course you would after all who
doesn't love a great deal right and when
it comes to great rates on insurance for
all the things in your life
geico can help like with insurance for
your car truck motorcycle boat and rv
even help with homeowners condo or
renter's coverage you could save even
more with a special discount when you
bundle your coverages plus add the easy
to use geico mobile app available
24-hour roadside assistance and more and
choosing to switch to geico becomes an
easy choice switch today and see all the
ways you could save with great rates and
discounts it's easy simply go to
geico.com to get a rate quote or contact
your local agent and get started seeing
how much you could save inside of you is
brought to you by shopify
ah it's the sound of another sale on
shopify the all-in-one commerce platform
to start run and grow your business
shopify gives entrepreneurs the
resources once reserved for big business
so upstarts startups and established
businesses alike can sell everywhere
synchronize online and in-person sales
and effortlessly stay informed scaling
your business is a journey of endless
possibility and believe me this podcast
started selling
our numbers were very low and shopify
makes it so easy this is two years later
that i've been doing the inside of you
online store and shopify really has
these numbers have grown exponentially
they are truly the masters of this like
mine shopify powers millions of
businesses from first sale to full scale
reach customers online and across social
networks with an ever-growing suite of
channel integrations and apps including
facebook instagram tick tock pinterest
and more gain insights as you grow with
detailed reporting of conversion rates
profit margins and beyond more than a
store shopify grows with you this is
possibility powered by shopify go to
shopify.com
inside all lower class for a free 14-day
trial and get full access to shopify's
entire suite of features grow your
business with shopify today go to
shopify.com
inside
right now shopify.com
what was it like you've
burden of truth is done
right did that upset you were you upset
that it got cancelled
no we wanted it to end there was no more
story to tell
really there's always a story to tell
isn't there
well there isn't that's what fans will
say the fans will say that they'll sing
there's always stories to tell
yeah yes i suppose that's true but um
the stories that we wanted to tell
were kind of done it was a show that
hinged a lot on
uh cases that revealed personal it kind
of had a finite structure to it
and we didn't want to i mean we pushed
it one season extra more than we had
planned to um
and we were really happy with what we we
ended up with and and we felt like it
was it was time to
retire the characters so you knew it
ahead of time or were they did they say
hey we're not getting you so you knew
the season the last season was the last
season did everybody know or did you
just know because you're an executive
producer no no we all we all knew i mean
mostly it was weird because i thought
that the cbc would announce that and
they never and they never did so we were
always like can we talk about this can
we so we just it was like a weird it was
a weird situation that way but yeah i
think most of us knew it was the end
yeah and how do you how do you react now
you know at your age and you the amount
of work you've done when it ends are you
sad are you fulfilled are you like do
you you just kind of move on and go
what's next
i think the i think the latter but i
it doesn't negate how meaningful the
experience was right especially on
burden of truth i it was such a
meaningful experience
and the people that i worked with and
the stories that we got to tell meant a
lot to me so
it feels like that's that's meaningful
but when i leave a show it feels like
i'm
it feels like okay done
but it's always felt that way i don't
know i mean i think i'm weird that way
you're not a crier you're not a big
crier i i am i'm a crier but i i don't
know that i cry about
like
work that much what do you cry
about a lot of things i'll cry movies or
crap books what's the last thing you
cried about what's the last thing you
cried about
i think i might have cried in a
succession episode about something
recently was it succession no i watched
nomad land for the first time
did you watch it i didn't see it
ryan you've seen it yeah it won the
oscar last
best year
it won the oscar for what best picture
really i didn't see it was francis
mcdormand uh
she's just on the road
no mad land no mad land yeah it's
beautiful and so yeah it's very sad but
hopeful um it's like it's kind of like a
road movie
really
maybe not in a way it is it seems like a
road movie to me it was beautiful and
about america and about
um
like mortality but also like the effects
of capitalism
and how capitalism fails us as a society
and the people that get left behind and
how you find meaning
when you're when you become useless to
society that
a society that values you for your
ability to produce
yeah are you an ugly crier or are you
like just kind of like oh you know i
mean when's the last time you had an
ugly cry kristen
because i have some of those it's been a
long time a long time you know those
just like i can't i can't get it
together kind of cry
yeah it's been a very long time very
long time since that's happened
thankfully because that normally happens
when something intense has happened yeah
exactly uh jack reacher are you gonna be
in jack reacher i am in jack reacher yes
i am how big of a part in jack reacher i
mean like half the episodes half of the
episodes i had no idea
yeah i
it's not like i'm like
on the lead cast or anything i just i'm
in like half the episodes it's a it's a
i got i have a you know georgian accent
and um a georgian accent
correct yeah like atlanta georgia or
georgia
it's a little more it's a little more
thick
because
i couldn't find i couldn't find the
perfect balance on the georgian accent
um but she's still like an educated
woman
right uh
but but she
i can't give away too much there's like
a twist but yeah it was it was a lot of
fun it was it was weird it was weird but
it was really fun i've never heard you
oh that's not true you had an indian
accent in in something you did right you
did that you did that very well but you
had a british accent and then her i had
a british accent yes british accent for
a video game
what's the easiest accent that comes to
you that you could just jump into at any
time i'm not going to do it now michael
damn it
not not a georgian accent
like when i say british is a very
like
london night like not like
i am not that good at accents i'm fine
at it do you have to really work at it
do you have to is it something you get a
a voice coach and really sit down with
them and work i'm great with sounds i'm
i'm i'm really good at like
i'm great at mimicking sounds so
i'll work with a coach and i'll learn it
fairly quickly but there are some sounds
that are just tough in every accent just
because my my
the way that i speak english just
doesn't
translate that well
um because i i love it it's so much fun
yeah you like diving into it do you
still like acting as much because i
never really thought he was someone who
loves acting and then i see your just
your career take off and you do you're
doing all these shows and you're the
lead and the producer
and you know earlier you were saying
produce early pretty surely pretty
certainly is that right
pretty sorry
you were you you enjoy like you want to
produce more like and do you think that
you like do you do you still love acting
or is it something like you know i'd
like to move away from acting and if i
could just produce
and and do your charitable work you
would do that
is that a tough question
no yes and no i love i do love acting i
have a lot of fun but i don't always
have fun
explain that explain that because i feel
the same way i don't like being on set
for 14 hours doing the same thing i get
really i feel like you get bored i get
really bored
right i don't get
although i haven't worked on a big
budget production for a long time so
except for reacher was like a it's a
little i have a lot of money um
but i am used to you know doing so many
scenes a day that you don't settle you
do like what two takes a scene and
you're gone like it's
so fast right so you don't have time to
get bored um
but i think that it's just about
sometimes it's just really draining
i think acting is really draining
and especially when you're working on a
tv show
um it's also really gratifying in those
experiences because you get to live with
the character for so long so so you get
to dig you know deeper and deeper into
somebody um
but i just i think it's it's
the emotional work of it
especially because i normally am playing
characters who are
it's not normally dramatic stuff so i'm
sad traumatized
uh whatever it is um and that sometimes
becomes
exhausting
i also don't love being in front of
camera as much anymore i mean not that i
loved it before but yeah it was
not any better than it was really why is
that do you still are you still shy are
you still just
what is it about being in front of a
camera well i think on a vanity level i
think getting older as weird as a woman
in front of the camera um
especially
to be frank because like i haven't
i think i've become
pretty decent as an actor but i wasn't
hired because i am like the best actor
in the room so
when you kind of get cast in a pocket of
being
pretty or or whatever it is it's like a
weird thing to
to go through the process of aging in
front of the camera and in many ways i i
like it because i feel confident enough
to let myself do that
and i feel like i i can do that
and that's the only way it's going to
change but it's also
an uncomfortable process
yeah i can understand that i mean
definitely agent you look back and you
look at when you were younger not you
proverbial you but all of us
and i'm like god my face was so thin i
was so
uh you know whatever it is you're
looking at yourself
and just judging yourself yeah and i you
know i wish i could just sometimes just
let go and just be like this is this is
who you are
um and this is this is your this is
aging this is life this is part of it
and um you're gonna get older and you're
gonna have little things on your face
and people are going to go oh look at
that oh they look and i always hate that
when people go god they look older i'm
like yeah it's 20 years ago
yeah and i think that i think the
reality is we
our show is pretty successful and that
was a long time ago so we're constantly
going to be compared
to
us
then you know
um yeah and you know you go to
conventions and there's just you know
our photos from
you know 20 years ago constantly so it's
just
it's it's a constant
conversation that i have to have in my
head
just to be like this is good this is
okay this is like normal it doesn't
matter
uh what people are talking about
ultimately you go through this you go
through this every time you film or
every time you're in front of the camera
no i don't i'm not that self-conscious
but it's only when
like if i see dailies and i'm like oh
that's not a very attractive shot uh and
then i'm like that's okay kristen it's
not about that it's about the scene and
the character like you like when i watch
actors i'm not going like well that's an
unattractive shot of them i'm going oh
my god that scene is so good or i love
the way that they that the wrinkles in
their face move in that scene or the
commitment the commitment the commitment
of the character the devotion to the to
the role the that's those are the great
actors you don't really have to worry
about like what they look like
well and like let's go to because we
were talking about earlier like francis
mcdormand
is a genius she is so good and i am
fairly certain that she
she is not
analyzing herself in that way
yeah i think when you can do that then
you've really you've gone to a good
place when you could just stop worrying
about what you look like because we all
do it to a certain point there is that
vanity there's that you want to look the
best you can so when people cause it you
know film lasts forever and that you're
like you know this is my image but at
the same time you look like you look and
you can't really control everything and
you're it's just stress that you're
you're dealing with that you
can't control
well and it isn't some substance of what
we are it's not the substance of the
work that we're doing it's
it very that doesn't really matter that
much when it comes to
who a person is yeah
but again we've been conditioned since
we were quite little
that's very true how do you um prepare
for a role do you think that now that
you're getting older that you have to be
on top of your game with exercise and
learning your lines and things like that
have you changed anything or
i've changed tons i didn't know anything
when i started i've it's taken me
all this time to kind of
patch work together some sort of
a process i mean i love research i love
school
i love reading you love school are you
still going to school are you done with
school i'm almost done
and what's your degree in
uh it's a it's a general bachelor's of
arts degree but but specializing in
history but no forensic science huh
no although i was looking online
yesterday um to see if there were some
you know
fully online masters programs and there
are some like uh criminal psych programs
out there but i'd have to you know
change my um i'd have to get a couple of
other courses i think before i could do
that
yeah um but yes
so
we were talking about acting yeah so
yeah what is what is your process as the
canadian stuff
that's extreme but i love research and i
like crafting
you know character backstories like i
love
getting a real deep sense of who a
person is what their life has been made
up of um you know all the usual stuff
and yeah i think at this point
i mean smallville was a different beast
entirely but i
i i have to know my lines especially the
last show i did which was so much legal
yeah legal jargon and i'd have courtroom
scenes block shot how do you learn your
lines
i just run them constantly constantly
before the beforehand until until the
day until i had it
because i get nervous courtroom scenes i
get nervous because there's a lot of
people there it's like doing theater so
there's a lot of people i'm performing
in front of and then i i get scared i
don't get scared normally but just with
all those people so i have to deal with
my nerves and i'm trying to like
navigate all of this courtroom jargon
that's going to be really stressful do
you ever think it god i wish i just had
a cue card i wish i just had an ear wig
no
no i couldn't do i couldn't i couldn't
act and have that some people could i
couldn't do that
but you have like monologues that you
have to go up there and do right yeah
and that scares the [ __ ] out of you
when i'm in front of people yes
absolutely because
the more people there are in a scene
the more and if they're moving the more
it takes to reset the scene if i'm by
myself if you and i have a scene where
the two-hander and i have to like yammer
on at you forever and i and i [ __ ] it up
i can just go back but if there's like a
bunch of people and we're all doing
stuff
there's props we have to go it takes so
long if you mess up to backtrack right
um and people lose their concentration
because they're backroom performers and
you [ __ ] up and people laugh and then
you've got to like get everyone
concentrated again it's just
too much
inside of you is brought to you by
creatures of habit that's creatures with
a k creatures of habit is an
in-your-face lifestyle and wellness
brand rooted in delivering nutritional
healthy habits alongside cozy apparel
the founder's story is one of hope
change adversity and now success
michael churnau made a decision 17 years
ago to change his life from struggling
with addiction and mental health to
living a life of wellness it wasn't as
easy as it sounds but the choice to find
a few healthy habits to commit first
thing in the morning was his gateway
into a better way of living and one of
those habits was oatmeal
meet the protagonist an incredibly
delicious highly optimized superhuman
oatmeal packed with 30 grams of
plant-based protein vitamin d3 omega-3
fatty acids probiotic and digestive
enzymes this is not just oatmeal the
protagonist is your daily wellness
insurance designed and created for
convenience whether you're running out
the door or like to prep the night
before the protagonist comes in four
easy to whip up recipes just add hot
water overnight in the fridge in the
microwave or into a smoothie and because
we want you to operate at your absolute
best in addition to being plant-based
the protagonist is also gluten-free soy
and dairy-free non-gmo and allergen free
i love that those are all the things
that i look into for health for
especially you know i'm getting older
man ryan i need to i need to eat well i
need something on the go i can't just be
eating crap and chips you know so this
is a really good alternative uh hop over
to creaturesofhabit.com that's creatures
with a k creatures of
habit.com
and use the promo code inside 15 that's
inside 15 to get 15 off your first
purchase
creaturesofhabit.com with a k and use
promo code inside15 for 15 off your
first order remember we are a direct
outcome of our daily habits some habits
will break you some will make you
creatures of habit is here to support
you on your journey of making greatness
a bigger part of your life inside of you
is brought to you by wondery
hey how do we make the most of our time
here on earth how do we bring meaning to
our life's work and what is the best
emoji to use when texting
these are the important questions asked
on the weekly interview podcast life is
short with justin long justin chats with
celebrities actors musicians artists and
more about how they can get the most out
of life recent guests include comedian
rob riggle and singer amy mann he digs
deep and each episode goes beyond what
you'd expect to hear on an interview
show and in an all new episode justin
talks with actor billy zane about his
long and storied hollywood career which
started with a small role in back to the
future
justin's candid interview style pulls
out some unexpected stories from billy
from his time on set in the new comedy
series mcgruber to his villainous role
in international blockbuster titanic
which he admits he secretly played like
a comedy and of course you'll find out
billy zane's favorite emoji too
life is short with justin long well
justin is one of the most likable guys
i've ever met and i think everybody in
hollywood agrees and he like i do gets
people to open up and that's what you
want to see and so uh i definitely love
and recommend justin long life is short
with justin long listen to life is short
with justin long on apple podcasts
amazon music or you can listen ad free
by joining wondering plus in the wondery
app
are you disciplined in terms of
exercise is that something that's
incorporated uh in your life
michael
i was a competitive gymnast both my
parents are very fit
i have exercised since i was
a kid and i i will always do it it's so
important to me i just it's funny
because i'm taking a um
anatomy
physical fitness class at school right
now i actually just got my final exam
before i got a physical fitness class
yeah so it's a health class
right study it's basically for people i
think who are interested in getting into
like kinesiology or personal training or
that kind of stuff but i just took it
because i'm interested so i've been like
building fake exercise programs for
for people um for fake hypothetical
people and do one for me and i
you want me to create a program for you
yeah but yeah that would be great you
already work out i mean i don't work out
very much probably a couple times
mostly michael you just need to
make sure that your cardiovascular
health is really good i don't do a lot
of cardio i have to 150 minutes of
moderate to visib moderate to vigorous
physical activity per week
150 what minutes
it's not that much
two and a half hours is what that is two
and a half hours so you can go walk
really fast for a while you can go for a
jog you can just make sure that your
heart rate is up at a decent rate
jeez ryan do you do that i was trying to
calculate i don't think so
you do that kristen what do you do
what do you do fair amount
no i mean are you on a treadmill or do
you go for a run i like running outside
you're like running out of during the
pandemic i hated running i hated cardio
right yeah with my back though it's the
impact so i can't really do that but i
can go on brisk walks
i could uh you know
i could bike if i want to but i'm on a
hill is it your back yeah it's just like
it's not great for your back when the
impact
i i do i am a member of a little club
that has a pool swimming would be
perfect if you could get in
some swimming is something that you
liked or like um
150 minutes like a stationary bicycle i
have one i just haven't used it
but for your back do is it like an
upgrade are you okay in an upright
bicycle or are you better
upright's fine i mean both are fine yeah
i think i should do that you only have
to do it like five times a week for 30
minutes you're really uh intense about
this 150 minutes a week like there's
something that you've read in this book
of uh
physiology uh what is it
yeah i think that the the research
suggests that you get a
huge boost in
benef health benefits at 150
minutes per week maybe my anxiety will
go down if i just uh work harder it will
help your anxiety really
yeah and you need to do two days of
resistance training which i think you
already do resistance like weights
do you have a trainer you just do it by
yourself
no i have an all women's gym that i go
to right now in in toronto and it's like
all it's like fun because it's it's all
barbell
strength training so we get to lift
heavy and i like doing that don't you
like going to an all-women's gym so you
don't have to have guys hit on you and
stare at you
yeah i i do
but but i don't know i don't know if
that would happen as much any anymore
what do you mean anymore
men are maturing
no
men are tend to gravitate towards
younger women
when they go to him oh
kristen you don't look your age i'm not
saying i'm not saying i'm just making a
comment okay
like
15 years old is when i got hit on the
most
15 men
oh yeah oh god
that's gross i'm sorry you had to deal
with that [ __ ] yeah me too
yeah it's something that probably haunts
you doesn't it
that's probably in a sense you might
want to have kids because you're like
you know they have to deal with that and
all that [ __ ] that they have to deal
with in the wrong way no
i i mean
i don't think i've thought about it that
way with kids but yeah but it's all and
a lot of a lot of girls go through that
at that age how do you feel about it
being the 20th anniversary of smallville
does it does it kind of like do you
think about that do you think like holy
[ __ ]
what do you think about
time goes by really fast
yeah it sure does yeah it just goes by
so fast
i think that's mostly and with the
pandemic too because it all happened at
the same time
these year the year and a half of the
pandemic went by so quickly and then
having the
you know because we didn't there was no
real differentiation in the days that
all kind of blurred together into this
one
massive time that just was like what
it's already been a year and a half
already and then with the 20-year
anniversary i was like
it just goes by so quickly
yeah you know do you miss anything about
it is there anything you miss that you
think back you know i really had fun
doing this i i miss this person i miss
this sort of camaraderie
i'm you know i missed working with you
tina tioli
i miss
joking around with steve oben and
i miss having steve was our wardrobe guy
who just uh let's just say steve was a a
great energy on set and spoke his mind
and would just tell it like it is
he did he did it indeed i remember him
walking in the trailer and go here's
your shirt and i'm like uh i don't
really like it because i don't care they
told me to give it to you just you can
wear it or you don't have to i don't
really give a [ __ ]
it's pretty much dead we were young
we were young and eager and
you know i was i just remember it it
just feels like it was so long ago
it really does feel like it was long a
long time ago it's like another lifetime
it is weird but what do you think about
when you're 70 or 80 and people saying
they just they remember smallville
that's what is that okay with you is
that does that bother you do you want to
be known for something else do you do
you hate talking about smallville
no i don't hate talking about it i also
will people remember i hope that the
substance of my life isn't measured by
things that people remember me for in
the general public
like i'd like the substance of my life
to be
smaller if that makes sense and deeper
how do you want to be remembered yeah
i don't know i've never i've honestly
never thought about how i because i'll
be dead
but i do i want to have
built meaningful relationships and
made some sort of positive impact on
those closest to me
i think that's it i i don't and the
world i think that you are someone like
you want to help with women's shelters
you're always whenever i talk to you
you're always looking how you can help
how you can help someone's life
i think that that's always been a part
of you
yeah that has that has been a part of my
life and it's you know
been it was derailed slightly um and
then i feel like i'm coming back
finding my way back to
understanding what that means for me and
going to school has been really helpful
for me to to get a better grasp on the
lay of the land and
[Music]
and have a deeper understanding of where
we're at
would you ever do a would you ever come
back to the dc universe or would you do
marvel would you do a marvel movie would
you do a dc movie would you come back on
a on a show like arrow and play a
character which is it something that you
don't really think about is it something
that you would consider or is it you
know how do you feel about that well we
get asked that question a lot
right i get asked that all the time
yeah so
i would never
i mean it would depend what it was
obviously but i'm not like immediately
opposed to it
do i struggle a little bit with how much
marvel's taken like taken hold of the
cinematic world i do a little bit yeah
but
you know
people have fun and they love it and i
think i guess that's what's that's what
matters so but yeah i wouldn't say
no to something like that i want to know
what it is i couldn't say yes or no
until i knew what it was what's the
character that you would like to play
what's a character the kind of character
if you were going to be a superhero what
would it be could i not be a superhero
okay what about a villain
okay would you rather be lex luthor than
clark kent
yes i would
i would as an actor that would be really
fun you had a really fun role
i've always thought that the
villainous roles were really fun
more complex there's a little more
freedom yeah i always felt like you
thought oh lana
lana what is she moping about this time
like you always felt like i want her to
be strong and i want her to be
this and you know it it took a long time
for that to sort of evolve
it did and i loved it when it did it was
really i think as an actor like that's
what's fun is being able to play
like secrets and
hide stuff and manipulate and
not present exactly what you're feeling
that's what's fun in acting is kind of
all of those layers yeah i'd like to see
you as a dark character someone that's
just kind of vicious
vicious and conniving and just so out of
character that would i mean have you
gotten to play something
similar to that because you've played
some great characters but have you ever
gotten to do something where you dive in
and play something really dark that's
against everything you know morals etc
i mean
broadly
smallville gave me a few opportunities
like that but they were so broad they
were really
kind of arch
you know not kind of nuanced looks at
that i think with joanna which is the
role that i played on burden of truth
she's obviously not an evil person but
there were things she did that were
morally questionable and she stepped up
to the line on a lot of
on a lot of um
wanting to get revenge or trying to
destroy somebody's life or whatever it
is so she was constantly kind of
pressing up against that line and i i
found that interesting um
and i guess that's villainous behavior
in some some ways the morally
questionable gray areas that people
flirt with or
or justify moving into would you play if
a producer called you and said kristen i
need you to gain about 25 pounds
20 pounds yeah and play a character like
sure that would be for me
yeah i don't know either but i'm just
saying like a charlize theron kind of
character and monster okay absolutely i
would love that you would love that yeah
you would just stop working out stop
your 150 minutes of cardio
there are some
like it would be fine but i also think
that it's not great on people actors
bodies so
to gain a ton and to lose a ton
that's like really unhealthy generally
but i mean if it was something great
yeah actually it's funny i was watching
um
last night we were doing a
contemporary jane austen
movies okay
which is basically just bridget jones
and clueless right so we were watching
bridget jones
and i was like she she's
like thin in this movie like i don't
understand and
renee silberg i think gained you know a
good 20 pounds for that role but she was
tiny in it it was it was crazy it's a
slight detour and made a slight teacher
but you wanted her to be bigger
yes
in the book she's bigger
i think i never read the book but from
what i understand she's supposed to be
chubby
and uh i didn't think she was chubby at
all so you're willing to be chubby
you're willing to be chubby you would be
chubby you would do anything if you love
the role yeah if it was healthy i i
would never want to hurt myself for a
while
i'm not that committed because there's
some roles there's like that guy in the
walking dead they say he would you know
he did and i'm not going to say his name
but like you know he didn't shower a lot
he smelled on set he wanted to be that
kind of character could you see yourself
doing that
what's the point
isn't that what makeup is
a touche
touche that's i think i get it if an
actor if that's their process
i commend you i am not that committed i
will never be that committed but i love
that people are that committed sometimes
it's tough to work with but i
i just if that's how you get the results
and i get to watch an incredible
performance
you do you as long as it's not harming
anyone else i would love to one day like
i don't know either cast you or
see someone cast you as a role that's
just completely added
character for you that you just i think
you'd be really good and i think you
would dive in pretty hard
it would be fun
that'd be great
i'd like to blacken your front teeth out
give you that georgian accent maybe a
[ __ ] eye maybe one eye that kind of
dragged you know just slightly off
just completely affect the way you look
it wouldn't be easy it wouldn't be easy
because you're a pretty girl pretty
woman
i could say that because you're my
friend um
this is [ __ ] talking with kristen crook
these are questions from my lovely
patrons if you guys want to join patreon
go to patreon.com inside of you these
are uh people that want to ask you some
questions so you could answer them if
you'd like
okay all right you're doing great this
is great you know when we first talked
you're like i'm boring i really have
nothing to say i don't know what you're
going to talk about but we find
something to talk about
i don't know if anyone else will find it
interesting i think so
i i love to i love talking to you it's
like the only time i really get to talk
to you unless we see each other at a con
or something i'd love to actually have
dinner with you one night when we're in
the same town and really catch up and
just like you know it's been a while
are you going to mexico i might
okay i might go to mexico you're going
to mexico
yeah unless kova goes crazy right are
you going to australia no i don't know
about you you should go to australia i
think you'd have a wonderful time it's
really really fun i don't know if
someone's like you know australia well
let me see what i can do i know the
people i know the people
uh stefa a i think it's stefa with
burden of truth finished do you have any
plans or any projects in the works or
would you rather take a break for a
while
good question i have um a project in
development right now that i'm working
on with peter mooney from burden and
eric my guy so we've got something in
development
very early stages which is really fun
i'm liking that and then i'm really
pushing to try and graduate i'd like to
graduate and be done with this uh
so i'm getting close to that hopefully i
just have one more semester um if if not
then it'll be that i'll be done after
this is school expensive
yeah it's not cheap
what does school cost
like for a semester
it depends how many credits basically by
credit you're paying for it by credit
were you doing were you doing burden
while you're going to school
i tried i can't do classes no way
too much work my brain can't i've tried
i just it's like when i come home and i
have to study and i don't have a little
ton of turn around and i i can't right
um but yeah it's not it's not it's not
cheap
yeah um did you mostly do virtual
because of the pandemic the whole thing
was virtual the whole thing was virtual
did you like that or do you like to be
in class no i love it do you know how
young people are in their bachelor's
degrees michael
they're 19.
i am an elderly lady you are not
compared to 18 i am
but i think you know well well whatever
i i understand i see that i i hear you
would you want to sit down
and like have discussions
with your gray hair and not yours
do you know what would be more
embarrassing
cheating off one of these kids
cheating being a 49 year old and having
to cheat off some 18 year old using cop
i'm like hey dude can i borrow your
notes bro like dude you're like 50.
are you serious i'm like yeah [ __ ] i
want to cheat man i need to cheat i need
to get through this class bro i want a
degree in kinesiology
um
little lisa what was one of the hardest
scenes you had to do on smallville
artist
that could be anything that could be
like you were embarrassed to do it or it
was like oh my god i can't believe i'm
doing this or you have that stupid
witches the witches
no that one was stupid but the vampire
episode
i got in so many fights with greg beeman
about that episode
that one that one was really hard for me
to do it just felt super gratuitous and
no one would listen to me about it so
i had to
fight my way through that one what about
physically have you has there ever been
a role that's just so physical that
you're just so exhausted
michael i played chun li
that's true
was that absolutely exhausting
yeah we worked it was thailand so we
worked seven no six days a week once i
worked 13 days straight and it was
mostly nights and it was all fight
sequences i was tired but i had a lot of
fun by the way do you think you could do
it now
no
really why is that
because when you're younger you just
have more energy more
working
working if i had enough turnaround and i
had a weekend maybe
yeah but it was demanding it was taxing
did you ever get injured
yeah because i was practicing a sword
sequence and i'm not used to swords and
they're really heavy and so my wrist i
woke up one day and my wrist was like
like fully swollen and i just had to but
that's the only injury i i got on that
production and i did crazy stuff i
jumped off of things with
like on wires from um which are they
called the cranes on the in the harbor
just flying through the air i did tons
of fight sequences i had i had it i had
a blast
yeah so you had fun doing that would you
do you
well you would do it again you would do
something again if it was the right
schedule is the right part you would
love to be more physical so much fun and
i'm pretty i'm pretty good at it like
i'm not i'm not i know you're a gymnast
you were you were an amazing
yes you were amazing for money
can you just still do some karate kicks
i think you've given me a karate kick
before yeah i can do it my hips aren't
are i don't
do a ton of stunt work anymore like when
i was on beauty and the beast i was
fighting all the time so i was used to
stuff i have to train a little bit to
get my my full range mobility back but
yeah dave p what are you looking forward
to most in 2022
graduating from
university that's what you're looking
for moving back to vancouver
what's the first thing you're going to
do when you go back to vancouver besides
see your parents and your family
what's the one place you want to go to
in vancouver that you miss i want to go
hiking where
well don't say maybe you shouldn't say
no i like i like going to i don't know
there's a there's a mountain that's very
famous in squamish um that's great for
hiking it's beautiful that's what that's
what i'd like to do and go to the beach
lots of going to the beach there's no
beach here and see tina tioli tina we'll
hang out and we'll go to the
um
little spanish tapas place that's near
our house and we'll have delicious food
and drink wine i love it danny i enjoy
kristen's book recommendations is there
a favorite book that she would like to
adapt for tv or film
adapt
somebody i have to check because i never
remember what i've read um
ah i wonder if they're doing it have you
read uh
ishiguro's no you haven't but for people
who have read clara and the sun
it is so beautiful
[Music]
this baby it came out this year it was
really popular clara and the sun
yeah and i i'd be really curious to see
this in a in a film i think that's a big
book how many pages is that book oh it's
not it's
it looks big it's something
it's like other pictures 300 pages okay
but the
it's not like no the margins are quite
significant yeah
so that's a book that you would consider
i mean yeah this book is gorgeous he's a
he's a beautiful writer he wrote he
wrote never never
said never let me go never let me go
neverland which is a great film did you
see that film ryan
ryan no he didn't
ray harada
what was something that you were
surprised to learn about one of your
castmates that could be any of your
castmates
it surprised me one of my castmates
um i think originally i was surprised
that erica grew up in like rural alberta
in a very religious family
i didn't know that
you talked to her i don't remember
talking about that yeah she did
really
yeah i'm gonna have to bring that up
when i talk to her again
yeah it's really interesting yeah i
think it's interesting
it's amazing sometimes you really just
when you're on set you don't know the
people you're working with you just kind
of like talk to him about like surface
kind of things and oh i saw this movie
this weekend but like you really don't
know them like i feel like i don't i
mean i i we never really talked in depth
too much tool with the podcast and now i
get to really know
a lot about you i feel like i learned a
lot about you
now i'm an open book though i'm an open
book you were never an open book
you had to get to really know kristin
yes i have to trust you you have to
trust let's just i understand that you
know you won the canadian award of
distinction
which is kind of cool like did you have
to give a speech
i did you did were you nervous as [ __ ]
i was so nervous i wrote it and i was
really nervous and it was up so i didn't
have to memorize it but like it was it
was funny because i think bill hader was
getting a special award that day
and so was paul feig and so they were
the ones that were sitting like right in
front of me but i was very nervous
giving that speech that's an honor
though how cool is that
it was lovely i felt very honored i
don't think i'll ever win an award of
distinction
i just don't think that's an award
that's going to be in my uh on my uh do
you have the award
i do it's up there
oh nice
i get it but it's too high yeah it's my
people's choice awards
also when people's choices are i never
wanted people's choice awards either
look at you uh you know i know you had
scoliosis as a kid do you have any more
issues with that
i mean i still have it it doesn't go
away what is it what happens when you
have scoliosis i mean do you have any
kind of bacteria curvature of your spine
so normally it depends how bad it is
some people have to get surgery i never
had to get surgery men's like mild to
moderate
um mostly it's pain so i noticed it when
i was you know a gymnast and my coach
saw it one day could see the curve in my
spine but i was getting really bad like
shooting pains down
my sciatic and it was just my back was
killing me so
i
i kind of had to
chill out on some of my gymnastics stuff
for a while but as an adult it doesn't
really bug me unless i'm standing like
if i go to a museum and i'm walking
around for hours and standing it's my
lower back gets sore but mostly they
always told me just stay strong and
it'll be fine so that's what i do solid
core i have mild scoliosis as well do
you i do very very mild i have a little
thing called spina bifida something
occulta that's just a slight little
thing that's there it's a slight but you
know i've had you know all the [ __ ] that
i've gone through but um
hey kristen do you uh
do you you don't go to therapy do you
have you ever gone to therapy
i haven't
i it's just
wary
of these kinds of things
not that i don't think people should go
to therapy i think it's great i just
for you it's not something that you you
know
it's just i've spent so much time
analyzing myself
in other contexts that they okay
that's fair
i don't i think one day i will once i
find the right
you know
i think for me what's the most important
about going to therapy is that uh you
know i could talk objectively to people
but also things come out
that were subconscious that i didn't
know
what were the major reasons behind some
of my
flaws or some of my insecurities or
anxieties and so things come out that
you're like oh that's what's causing
that so there's more of an understanding
of why i do the things i do and where
i've been and what i've become and
evolution and all that stuff so that's
that's kind of that's what's up what
kind of therapy do you do do you do like
cbt yeah cognitive behavioral therapy so
that's like you know um
and i just try i'm trying the somatic
therapy oh interesting i've heard about
it yeah it's interesting and she you
know she was like
the other day we're having a it's
obviously a zoom but she said if you put
your right arm under your armpit
and right hand under your arm on your
left armpit and then your other your
left arm just below your shoulder
and kind of just hold yourself for a
minute
it kind of calms you
and she had a reasons for doing it and i
started to do it
and i really started to feel calm it's
almost like you're holding yourself like
you're giving yourself a hug it's weird
but like i just started this so i can't
really talk in depth about it but
somatic therapy
um yeah there's so many there are so
many options
therapy-wise yeah having studied a bunch
of like
entry-level psych at this point there's
just there's just so much you can do
yeah
was there anything else that you
anything coming up or anything that i
should know about that i haven't
mentioned
no i don't think so
i think you're pretty much well i'm
i love that you talk to me and you're
always so open you can easily say you
know i don't want to do it and i would
understand but you know it's like i
don't you know it's like every year i'm
like i gotta catch up with you
but i really i really enjoyed this and i
really uh i thought it wasn't boring at
all i hope people think feel the same
way i don't think you're a boring person
i think you are like tom said a little
bit of a mystery i think you'll always
be sort of a mystery and i wish i was a
mystery but i'm not
i'm really i'm not a mystery once you
know me
it just takes time and i don't see you
guys enough for it to be especially like
tom i've hardly talked to tom like ever
it's in the span of our
many years of working together we
haven't had a ton of conversations well
one thing's for sure we both really like
you we both really yeah genuinely like
you and it's nice to have worked with
someone for so long and even though
there's some distance and we haven't
seen each other a lot to still you know
care for someone and
appreciate them for who they are and
respect them and that's uh that's what
we have for you so i especially
so thanks for talking to me again today
thanks michael yes this was great um are
you off to go play now
no we're gonna do some ads for the show
because the ads keep us flowing to
disney world oh yeah i'm gonna be going
to disney world soon with some friends
and you know i like to be a kid and go
on rides and just forget who i am for a
few days
so that would be nice and i got a
christmas tree but it's dying i don't
know why it's dying i water it
how long ago did you get it and then
like well probably 10 days ago then my
grandmother's like why do you have a
christmas tree you're a jew i'm like i'm
not really practicing and i think
christmas is cool
i like christmas trees when the [ __ ] can
i have a crazy because i don't care what
you do you could have a christmas tree
so
anyway
um
i love you girl thank you so much for
for coming on again
thank you thank you thank you all right
i'll talk to you later have fun bye
ryan say goodbye to kristen bye kristen
bye
i mean there's not a sweeter person
there really isn't
you got lucky with that co-star i mean
yeah she could have been like think
about it she could have been a pain in
the ass i was the pain in the ass
she was just delightful she's always
delightful i love having her on people
are interested people love her they do
so kristen if you're still listening
which you probably won't listen to this
podcast i love you and i appreciate you
and uh you're coming back next year so
get ready
um thank you guys again if you want to
get anything from the inside of you
online store go there new lunch boxes
signed by tom willing and myself marvel
lunch boxes bunch of other great stuff
sunspin.com if you want to get tickets
to the next sunspin show which is
february 26th 2 p.m and 6 p.m pacific
standard time
it's gonna be a blast
and um patreon join patreon the lovely
patreon that really helps the podcast
more than you know so if you want to
give something go to patreon
p-a-t-r-e-o-n dot com inside of you
thank you christian cook for being a
great guest how you doing ryan i'm doing
okay i've recovered from being shocked
inside of my head yeah you're kidding me
you were shocked
yeah i was worried about you for a
second i'm good is it weird that i got
worried about the next guest who's gonna
wear those headphones i'm wearing i'm
wearing my same headphones okay it's all
me i just i i generate a lot of static
electricity especially these days it's
so hot in la right now and i just
cannot stop shocking myself oh what are
you gonna do
what are you gonna do buddy i gotta stop
listening to shock jock radio
radio
all right let's give a shout out uh as
one of the top patrons you get a shout
out in the podcast every week so these
are the top patrons let's shout them out
nancy d leah s sarah v little lisa ukico
jill e brian h nico p robert b jason w
kristen k not kristen krug
emilia oh allison l raj c joshua d cjp
jennifer and stacy l correct see if i
just throw it out there he's gonna get
it jen asked jamal f janelle b roger
uh and hammerstein
yes
kimberly e mike e eldon supremo 99 more
ramira santiago m chad w leanne p janine
r maya p maddie s belinda
m
and this correct n is correct
uh where is that one
chris h dave h spiderman chase sheila g
brad d ray h that's ray harada i know
that tab of the t
tom n liliana a michelle k talia m betsy
d
chad l rochelle marion meg k dan n angel
m rhiannon c corey k super sam coleman g
dev nixon michelle a jeremy
piven
c correct jeremy c cody r gav
inator gavinator david c john b brandy d
uh
four divorce correct camille s
the c joey m
willie f kristina e adelaide n omar i
lena n eugene and leah chris p nikki g
corey patricia heather l jake b bobbitt
ed a
a bowl
a bowl f
joshua b a bowl did i say that right i
hope i did because that she messaged or
they messaged me
and i
was messing the name up
a bowl
tony g joshua b shawn r and megan t
those are the top tier patrons they give
back in more ways than you can believe
keep the podcast afloat so again if you
want to give back you can go to
patreon.com this is always a treat for
me uh having these guests open up about
their lives spread the word if you like
it um you know just get the word out
there's so many podcasts to listen to
ryan there's so many podcasts that you
know i'm just blessed that people are
still listening to mine hopefully they
find it interesting and they get to
learn about people it's not just
hollywood [ __ ] it's it's real stuff
hopefully and you know real people and
uh that's all you can hope for and a
little bit of hollywood [ __ ] a
little hollywood [ __ ] but like
ultimately it's just about a candid open
conversation about like hey man
you know what's going on with you what
happened to you what
where are you what happened to you what
happened to you it is a lot of that it
is uh
but i hope it doesn't get old and i hope
you stick with me and i really
appreciate it thank you for allowing me
to be inside of each and every one of
you i hope your week is beautiful
um
i'll see you next week ryan
from the hollywood hills in california
i'm brad tales and i'm michael rosenbaum
a little wait for the camera
we love you and uh thank you for
allowing me inside of each and every one
of you like i said and i'll i'll talk to
you
before you know it right ryan
we'll talk again all right see ya
[Music]